this episode is brought to you by
curiosity stream curiosity stream is a
subscription streaming service that
offers thousands of documentaries and
non-fiction titles from some of the
world's best filmmakers including
exclusive originals why not check out
apocalypse world war one which draws in
over 300 hours of archival footage
apocalypse world war one traces the
journeys of civilians and soldiers who
fought for survival and one of the
darkest times in history examine an era
that fundamentally changed the worldwide
balance of power from the war's outbreak
in 1914 through its duration to the u.s
intervention and the treaty of
versailles curiosity streams available
on many platforms i often read them all
out but look if you've got a screen a
smart device of some kind you're gonna
be able to watch curiosity stream it's
also available worldwide which is great
so go to curiositystream.com
forward slash biographics for unlimited
access the world's top documentaries and
non-fiction series and right now you
guys can use the promo code biographics
to save 25 of the cost of an annual
subscription which comes out to only
14.99 a year which is crazy cheap i
swear i have streaming services that
charge that much monthly so again
curiositystream.com forward slash
biographics 25
off which makes it
14.99 for the whole
year and now back to today's video
the sicilian mafia has been considered a
creeping unstoppable force whose grip on
the territory and the lives of honest
citizens cannot be vanquished by the
state the aura of invincibility has
taken legendary overtones as we often
see mafia dons being celebrated as folk
heroes in film and fiction but what of
the norman who gave all their energies
sanity and lives to defeat this monster
in today's biographics we're going to
chart the rise struggles and
controversial methods
of one of them a little-known historical
figure at least outside his native italy
a man who in the early 1920s was pulled
out of retirement for one last job a
mandate from mussolini himself to crush
the mafia whatever it took a man who
largely succeeded at his task only to be
hindered by the very political structure
who had given him full powers this is
the story of cesare mori better known as
the iron prefect
on the 22nd of december 1871 a boy was
born in paleo northern italy his parents
abandoned him at birth and he was raised
in the local orphanage under the name
primo derby his natural parents
acknowledged him only in 1879 and they
changed his name to cesare mori a
difficult start to life bred a young man
accustomed to harsh and disciplined
environments cesare enrolled in turin's
military academy and after a stint in
the army he joined the police after
serving in northern italy the young
officer was put to the test with a
transfer to sicily in 1904 this is when
mori first got first-hand knowledge of
that criminal organization known as the
mafia to outsiders and to its members as
kosa nostra our thing or our own
business mafia gangs have been around
for at least 40 years to oversimplify
they were first born as private security
companies protecting the interests of
wealthy landowners gradually they
branched out into the very criminal
activities they were supposed to fight
kidnappings robberies and cattle
rustling eventually they established a
monopoly of armed violence mainly in
rural sicily they exploited this
position by imposing a crippling
protection racket they were virtually
undisturbed in their activities shielded
by a network of corrupt officials and
the omert of common citizens the murder
is often described as a formalized code
of silence it is more of an ingrained
habit bred by generations of mistrust in
public authorities and fear of criminal
reprisals maury would not let himself be
intimidated by mafia threats nor was he
discouraged by lack of cooperation to
him mafioso were just ordinary bandits
and they should be treated as such he
distinguished himself by conducting
several high-profile arrests in the
province of japanese western sicily but
eventually he got on the wrong side of
his superiors they judged his methods to
be too heavy-handed and frequently
accused him of abuse of power eventually
in january of 1915 he was transferred to
florence where he was promoted to deputy
commissioner however a man of his skill
could not be kept away from the real
action for very long
in may of 1915 the kingdom of italy
declared war on austria-hungary and
entered world war one thousands of young
sicilians were called to arms but many
of them went awol and took to the hills
swelling the ranks of bandit gangs not
all of these gangs were affiliated to
kosa nostra but they shared their
methods and tight grip on the territory
the ministry of the interior had the
right man for the job deputy
commissioner mori i will not describe
all his actions save for one to give you
an example of mori's strategy and
tactics in 1916 the lawman set his sides
on the gang led by grisafe it only
included five bandits but they were
heavily armed and could count on a
network of allies and informants mori's
signature strategy consisted of two
stages first destroy the enemy's supply
and support network second surround the
foe and force them into a fire fight or
into surrender in the grassafi case
maury and his men descended upon the
town of calter belotta in southwestern
sicily and rounded up some 300 allies of
the bandits the outlaws now isolated
made a huge mistake they hoisted a black
flag above their mountain hideout
signifying their will to fight on maury
took up the gauntlet and launched a
surprise attack surrounding the enemy
base when maury entered their cave he
found that grasafi and friends had
escaped through a secret passage leaving
behind their horses and a military-grade
arsenal the deputy commissioner was a
capable sleuth he ordered his men to set
the horses free and to follow them the
habit loving animals naturally rode to
another location a farmhouse which
turned out to be a second layer for the
gang time for stage two maury's men
surrounded the house at night ready for
stealth action but the outlaws spotted
the police force and opened fire an
intense fire fight ensued in which maury
directed concentrated volleys of rifle
rounds against the doors and windows of
the farm the building was almost
demolished by the bullets but luckily no
side suffered any casualties eventually
the gang surrendered this and other
successes made maury a household name
and a hero celebrated by the press yet
the law man was far from happy he knew
it dealt a crippling blow to some of the
foot soldiers fighting for the cosa
nostra but he also was aware that the
criminal organization's leaders and
patrons were still hiding in high places
the true lethal blow to the mafia will
be given when we are able to make
roundups in prefectures police
headquarters employers mansions and
ministries
[Music]
following his promotion the commissioner
was transferred again ending up in
bologna where he served from february
1921 to august 1922. on that occasion he
was appointed prefect in the italian
civil service the prefect is the
representative of the government for a
province while not a member of the
police forces a prefect has the
authority to coordinate their strategy
and activities maury landed in bologna
at the worst possible time the fascist
party was on the rise its members
organized in paramilitary squads of
black shirts roamed bologna in its
suburbs engaging in violent action
against communist workers on strike and
left-leaning farmers elsewhere police
forces turned a blind eye to fascist
street violence they were seen as the
lesser evil a necessary nuisance which
could contain and prevent a communist
uprising in italy but maury would not
have any of that on the 25th of may some
hundred black shirts led by former navy
captain cabardoni laid siege on the town
of santa viola attacking farm laborers
and factory workers with hand grenades
the prefix response was decisive he sent
an attachment of carabinieri a
militarized police force akin to the
french owned on maury's men dispersed
the fascists arresting many of them but
cavadoni got away later that night his
body was found in bologna torn apart by
a grenade his fellow party members
alleged he had been killed by the
communists and bathed for blood but a
police inquiry led by mori found that
cavadoni had died by accident while
assaulting a farmer's cooperative the
local section of the nationalist fascist
party intensified their actions against
communists and socialist organizations
but most of all they declared war on the
prefect twenty thousand black shirts
convened on bologna demanding for mori
to resign the tough lawmen responded by
barricading the prefecture and the
police headquarters resisting attacks
from militiamen and political pressure
to quit his job eventually in august the
ministry of the interior transferred
maury to barry southern italy the
blackshirts had now got free reign over
bologna a few weeks later at the end of
october 1922 the fascist party staged
their march on rome king victor emmanuel
iii appointed benito mussolini as prime
minister of the new coalition government
with the new cabinet in place maury was
quickly dismissed and sent to an early
retirement in florence but it wouldn't
last for long
in may of 1924 benito mussolini traveled
to sicily for an official visit he and
other party leaders were aware of the
blight of cosinastra their political
program was founded on law and order
therefore they could not tolerate the
presence of large criminal organizations
and yet the mafia had backed fascists
and their allies in local elections a
common practice inherited from previous
political systems the visit was the
occasion for il ducey to draw a clean
slate and sever any connections between
the local administration and crime on
the 9th of may he declared in a speech
it should not be tolerated any longer
that a few hundred delinquents overwhelm
impoverish and damage a magnificent
people such as this the last draw was
drawn by mayor don francesco kutzia of a
small town near palermo the politician
and mafia boss glanced at mussolini's
bodyguards and told the duchess you are
with me you are under my protection what
do you need all these cops for the
leader was furious how could a two-bit
don believe he could be above the law
how could he believe his crime syndicate
be a replacement for the state mussolini
resolved to crush kosanostra he needed a
lawman with a proven track record and
knowledge of the territory more
importantly he needed someone who would
not be intimidated by a powerful
opponent well how about one of the few
prefects who had actively opposed the
rise of fascism and that's when maury
received the call
retirement was over on the 2nd of june
1924 mori was appointed the prefect for
the mafia-riddled province of tripani
mussolini gave him clear instructions
you have carp launch the authority of
the state must be absolutely
re-established in sicily if the laws in
force hinder you this will be no problem
we will draw up new laws maury
immediately applied stage one of his
strategy undermine the power base of the
mafia in this specific case he focused
on weakening the military strength of
the local gangs first he withdrew all
permits to carry firearms then he
heavily regulated the recruitment of the
campieri these were armed watchmen
looking after large estates many of whom
were hired as foot soldiers by cosa
nostra now all campieri had to be
scrutinized and appointed by a
provincial commission then mori went on
the attack targeting the most profitable
criminal enterprise around tripani
cattle rustling traditionally stolen
cattle were butchered and sold on the
black market but in recent years the
mafiodons had found that they could make
more money by holding large herds at
ransom maury reasoned that rustlers had
to look after the kidnapped animals
traveling across the countryside on
horseback mori identified the likely
routes where criminals could find fresh
water food and shelter for the cattle
with accurate maps in hand the police
and carabineri were able to ambush
hundreds of cattle rustlers red-handed
the prefect continued to repress
organized crime well into 1925. his
methods were harsh even brutal so much
so that the delegation of fascists from
tripani wrote a petition to mussolini
demanding that maori be transferred
somewhere else the petition ended up in
the bin and its signatories were all
expelled from the party the prefect not
only continued to operate but was even
promoted on the 20th of october 1925 he
was appointed the prefect palermo the
regional capital as such he would have
authority to fight the mafia across the
entire island
the iron prefect took to the task with a
grand strategic plan he was to conquer
the hearts and minds of sicilians to
restore their trust in institutions and
demolish the sense of fear of respect
which ordinary citizens placed on
mafioso on the operational level he
would approach the task as a military
campaign he assembled his army which he
dubbed the inter-provincial police squad
this was a force of some 800 policemen
and carabineri with jurisdiction over
the whole of sicily and answering only
to him he took great care in recruiting
officers who were local to the mafia
infested areas so that they could easily
blend in and collect intelligence the
interwar provincial police would target
one town village or entire district at a
time first undercover officers
identified the local mafioso and their
allies then they left the area allowing
for the waters to quiet down in the
meantime uniformed officers surrounded
and cordoned off the area of operations
finally maury's men swept in swiftly
carrying out massive roundups which
resulted in hundreds of arrests this
method required the targeted criminals
to occupy the same area at the same time
should this not happen naturally maury
resorted to a shrewd tactic he had
realized that gangs in the provinces
relied for strategic direction on the
palemo families the so-called dome
exploiting this fact he forged messages
from the dome asking subordinates to
meet in a secret location these meeting
places were not secret to the
inter-provincial squads who descended
upon their quarry in force when possible
the prefect refrained from open fire
fights with the outlaws he always
preferred to confiscate their goods and
arrest their network of allies and
families thus forcing them to surrender
such methods heard on the heavy-handed
side resulting in the arrest of innocent
civilians and the destruction of their
property maury even encouraged his
younger policemen to move in with the
wives of bandits on the lamb threatening
their honor this was an affront that no
full-blooded sicilian would tolerate and
many men left their lairs with vendettas
in mind only to be immediately arrested
in some cases though arrests were not
that easy leaders and gangs did not fall
into morrow's traps and opened fire
resulting in pitched battles with the
police force for those occasions mori
had issued specific instructions to his
men should the confrontation happen at
night shoot only if absolutely necessary
they had to exploit darkness and stealth
to creep in on their targets if shots
were fired during the day it's a whole
different story maury's men had been
trained to encircle the enemy in tight
formation whilst keeping cover and then
opened fire in a concentrated fashion
the approach stunned the outlaws on most
occasions leading them to accept
surrender but some mafioso could boast
remarkable arsenals and had no qualms in
firing back with mouser rifles heavy
machine guns or hand grenades heavy
casualties were suffered on both sides
but enough of theory let me give you a
practical example the siege of the town
of gunji mauri's most celebrated
accomplishment the effective yet
heavy-handed operation would earn him
the title of iron prefect bestowed by
the national press
[Music]
at the end of 1925 the prefect had
planned to score a spectacular success
to increase the prestige of his forces
and show to the sicilian people that the
state could be relied upon on the 1st of
january 1926 the iron prefect chose the
site for his pitched battle gunge within
the palermo province home to a gang 130
strong mori first ordered his squads to
surround a circular area around genji
with a 20 kilometer radius as he
expected with the police and the winter
cold creeping in many suspects flocked
to the town once this happened the force
moved closer to the town occupying the
farms owned by the mafioso and their
supporters confiscating goods and
slaughtering cattle the bandits felt the
noose titan went into hiding occupying
well-stocked well-concealed layers
underneath street level at this stage
maury received reinforcements from
palermo which included units of his old
black shirt foes with this formidable
force mori and his right-hand man police
commissioner espanol completely cordoned
off ganji the prefect sent a telegram to
the mayor which was relayed to the other
inhabitants via a town crier i summon
the fugitives and bandits who are in
your territory to give themselves up
within 12 hours on the lapse of which i
shall proceed to extreme measures the
ultimatum went unheeded and so came the
measures more animals were slaughtered
and sold to townsfolk at bargain prices
all the wells supplying ganges with
water were shut down and many houses
belonging to mafioso were occupied by
maoris and spanos squads there were even
allegations that these men raped the
wives and daughters of the fugitives the
locals while not happy with what
amounted to military occupation started
to lose respect for those made men whom
they had feared and supported just a few
days earlier after 10 days of tense
standoff one by one the mafioso of gunji
surrendered to the man the press called
the iron prefect in his memoirs mori
describes that the citizens of gundry
burst into a homeric burst of laughter
mocking the fate of these legendary
criminals
[Music]
following the victory at gunji the iron
prefect replicated the approach in other
mafia strongholds in a subsequent round
up the inter-provincial squads locked
their handcuffs on the blood-stained
wrists of don vito cassio pharaoh a
high-ranking boss considered to be the
inventor of the protection racket mori
also cracked down on a widespread
practice in rural areas mid and large
estate owners were cowed by mafioso into
renting out their lands and properties
at ridiculously low prices these lands
remained largely unproductive and
landlords suffered heavy financial
losses while not as exciting as a siege
or a roundup maury's instigation of a
large-scale review of tenancy contracts
ended up with these nefarious tenants
being pushed out of the countryside but
as mori's methods were praised by
fascist propaganda his methods also came
under question for being too brutal and
downright illegal once again allegations
landed on mussolini's desk that the
prefect and his men indulged in rape
torture and hostage taking nonetheless
the iron prefect and commissioner spano
pressed on with their crusade backed by
a third ally the judicial system this
was state attorney and head prosecutor
luigi giampietro who collected thousands
of witness accounts and was able to drag
to court some pretty big fish for
example the prefect and the prosecutor
built a dossier against fascist mp
alfredo cutso who was accused of
receiving kickbacks and favors from
mafia families the trial started in
november of 1927 kutso was initially
found guilty and expelled from the party
this apparent victory though turned sour
for the iron prefect the mp appealed his
sentence and the trial dragged on into
1929. in the meantime kutsow's dismissal
created a vacuum of power within the
sicilian section of the fascist party
which was quickly filled in by large
estate owners that were as cozy with the
mafia as their predecessor meanwhile
pressure had grown for the duche to
remove mari from his duties
enough was enough mussolini obliged and
sweetened the pill with an appointment
as senator and after all it looked like
the lawman had achieved his goals by
1929 11 000 people were dragged to court
many of them were innocent civilians
caught in the indiscriminate round-ups
of mori's squads many more were
acquitted after key witnesses were
threatened or killed but 1200 mafioso
were given sentences ranging from a few
months in prison to life an
unprecedented result more importantly
crime rates have plummeted when mori
took charge in 1925 the province of
palermo had recorded 268 homicides 298
robberies and 45 acts of cattle rustling
in 1929 there had been only five murders
three robberies and a mere two cases of
stolen herds by looking at these figures
it looked as though cosa nostra had been
thoroughly and utterly crushed this was
confirmed by a former mafioso turned
informant the mafia hardly existed
anymore mafioso had a hard life
the music changed in truth the now
senator mauri had won many battles but
he had not won the war most of the foot
soldiers and many of the mid-level
bosses had been wiped out but the dome
of top-level dons had barely been
touched many of them had fled the
country people like carlo gambino and
joseph bonanno relocated to new york
contributing to the rise of organized
crime in the u.s and what about the
campaign to win the hearts and minds of
sicilians many civilians had indeed lost
respect for criminals and had an
increased sense of pride and trust in
the government but mori had failed to
address the socio-economic conditions
which had pushed many youngsters into
the arms of organized crime if anything
it made them worse after landowners had
been freed from the scourge of bargain
price leases they took advantage of the
situation by increasing rent by a
thousand percent this affected most
rural workers and sharecroppers creating
a generation of impoverished and angry
sicilians ripe for the taking
in his later years senator mauri
continued to voice his views on sicily
and the mafia he insisted that the
government still had to invest more time
and resources into solving the problems
of that land but few years were eager to
listen to his complaints the once lorded
iron prefect died in relative obscurity
on the 5th of july 1942. his memoirs
were published in 1932 with the title
the last struggle with the mafia alas
the title proved to be wishful thinking
on july 9 1943 allied forces landed in
sicily driving out axis forces in a
matter of weeks following the invasion
the allies appointed civil servants
which did not have any ties to fascism
unfortunately many of them had ties to
cosa nostra or members of the old
families returned from their exile in
the states in many cases these former
bosses and maid men had even
collaborated with anglo-american forces
providing useful intelligence and
contacts the work of the iron prefect
had been undone in a span of less than
15 years and cosa nostra would return to
plague the land more powerful than ever
sure maury's methods were controversial
and many of his tactics would not find a
place in modern democracy at four years
activity could not instigate the
sweeping social reforms needed to
eradicate organized crime but his story
proves that even a cancer within the
state such as cosa nostra can be
effectively fought some of mori's
methods including targeting the wealth
of bosses and staging large show trials
would be picked up by later generations
of lawmen such as public prosecutors
giovanni falcone and paolo borcelino
whose stories we might tell
another day
[Music]
you